now we know that square root of 2 is an
irrational number if you use a
calculator to calculate the value of
root 2 you will get something like 1
point 4 1 4 2 1 3 5 and so on this value
that you get is actually non terminating
it is never ending
also you will not find any pattern in
the digits after the decimal hence it's
also called a non recurring decimal
there is no pattern that occurs again
and again these kinds of numbers are
called
irrational numbers consider square root
of 3 for instance you will get its value
as 1 point 7 3 2 0 5 0 and so on even
this decimal is non terminating and non
recurring so root 3 is also an
irrational number you can try
calculating the values of root 5 root 6
root 7 or rotate you will find that all
of them result in nonterminating
non-repeating decimals but wait root 9
equals 3 this is a rational number yes
root 9 is not an irrational number in
fact square root of any perfect square
will be a rational number but the square
root of any number which is not a
perfect square will always result in an
irrational number here's the interesting
part if you know these two points well
you can even form an irrational number
by yourself let's see how we have to
form a number which does not end and
does not repeat any pattern something
like 2 point 0 1 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 0 1
and so on here the number does not end
and is also non recurring this means
that there is no pattern that repeats
forever you can even have a number like
fifteen point two three four nine four
four nine four four four nine four four
four four nine and so on this is
also irrational as it is non terminating
and non-recurring where does this
concept help us say your rafts to find
two irrational numbers between one point
two three and one point two five
remember one point two four is incorrect
as its terminating we need a
nonterminating non-repeating decimal yes
but we know that one point two four is
between these two numbers after one
point two four we can start writing 0 1
0 0 1 0 0 0 1 and so on
that's one irrational number between
these two numbers again let's write 1
point 2 4 and this time we write 0 2 0 0
2 0 0 0 2 and so on after it that's your
second irrational number
so to find irrational numbers between
two numbers just write a rational number
between them and then add nonterminating
non-repeating digits after it